yeah whiteness and the patriarchy are
kind of hand in hand I do believe it
comes from the Roman slave state it was
essentially the Romans were racist
genocidal Maniacs that would conquer and
murder and enslave other people that
weren't pure blood Roman they were like
the Nazis of the time if the Nazis had
won and conquered the half the planet
yeah it wasn't just the Romans but the
Roman patriarchy the Roman the church
that they created like has done such
damage in the amount of slavery that
they imposed on people and and it still
is like bled through into our society we
have like white Roman Heritage but it's
like it's not the skin color that's
where we that's where it exactly it
starts to get blurry we gotta look past
the skin color and look at the actual
patriarchy the we even call ourselves
Patriots like that's a male dominant
thing they say God is a man that's male
dominant crap it doesn't have to be like
that you know he's going full feminist
yeah I was gonna say I don't think I
agree with you no one you don't have to
well